[Musique]
décidément l'émission pékin express n'en
finit pas de se retrouver au coeur de
polémiques au sujet de son éliminé de
l'aventuré qui se plaignait du montage
de l'émission pour lui il a été présenté
de façon très désagréable aux
téléspectateurs et assure que le montage
y est pour beaucoup
quand on met en avant un personnage qui
est chez que scénario on voit pas super
pizza express pour s'énerver
cette fois ci c'est si n'diaye rose
marie les deux copines de l' aventure
qui reproche à la production le montage
particulièrement tendancieux des plans
dans les douches très insistants alors
que les deux jeunes femmes se trouvaient
en maillot de bain mais ce qui a choqué
le plus dans leur portrait c'est le
commentaire un peu lourd de la voix off
qui se permettait de parler du corps des
deux candidates
ces parisiennes au corps et à l'esprit
bien affûté sont venus pour gagner
un passage que n'a pas manqué de relever
les internautes alors pékin express à
nouveau attaquée sur le montage
comprenez vous la colère des candidats
je vois beaucoup beaucoup de rouge
daniel des candidats tout est en fait
aussi devrait avoir un droit de regard
sur tout ce serait pas mal et c'est
surtout que là les internautes sont
d'accord avec non excusez-moi le la
scène de la douche avait été comme
mathieu l'enfer producteurs de lait là
on parle des candidats des deux
candidates qui se sont plaints de
malades de la scène de l on trouvait ça
un petit peu insistants on se serait cru
dans un vieux film attendu au regard des
lecteurs regardez moi c'est regarder un
petit peu choqué là les candidats n'ont
qu'une hâte faire un brin de toilette
ils ont des sanitaires à l'extérieur
donc évidemment cette année toilettes
comme on connaît nous il se douche avec
des jarries fier des jerrycans qui
rentrent réseau
bon j'avoue je crains un peu parce que
quand j'ouvre la porte du hall 1 3 4 cas
pas je me suis tout de suite s'est
poursuivie
enfin plaisir la rochelle extérieur les
plaines du coup
pour un plein de bleus
pour m
du coup je me douche je suis très
heureuse de me coucher je suis très
contente se voit fait ça mais par contre
je t'ai pas sur la pointe des pieds quoi
je suis en
non
[Musique]
ok là quand on regarde moi je vais
essayer je vais essayer d'être neutre
mais en fait je le suis pas du tout je
trouve ça un peu excessive quoi ça sert
vous savez le problème elle s'appelle
l'audience à voilà c'est ça le problème
de pékin express qui est une émission
que j'adore fondamentalement c'est que
cette année les audiences sont quelque
peu en berne par rapport au succès des
années précédentes donc à l'instar des
missions telles que koh lanta parce que
c'était aussi une émission d'aventuré
plein grès je regarde pas ça pour voir
la fed ont un an pour atteindre l'argent
soit je continue les enfants arrêtés moi
quand je vois ces images ça me rappelle
le la petite polémique qui avait autour
de koh lanta où l'on montrait pareil des
femmes en maillot de bain en train de se
ménager pour ça et là je trouve qu'on
répond une fois plus aux sirènes de la
télé réalité pour faire un peu tu
commences télé réalité de ma chaise
reste chez en tant que ça j'en ai marre
d asile écoutez on va faire de la télé
on fait les programmes t il d'accord on
est filmé sous une douche mais ne te ces
fameux à filmer deux sous une douce si
tu veux pas que les images s en servir
de dévoiler les images auraient permis
aux travaux mais quand tu soulignions
valverde louis est normal mais j'ai pas
dans un jeu dans lequel approndis haut
mais je ne savais pas j'ai pas envie ça
me dit elle a raison excusez moi moi si
je parle non qu'on me montre en maillot
de bain et qu'on peut faire une émission
je dis que je filme pas en maillot de
bain ou tu te bats mieux formés mais
lâchez tout vingt ans passés dans la
salle laurier mais les pib intéressante
parce qu'on les voit prendre une douche
dans un endroit c'est à prendre mais
qu'elle se lave on n'a pas eu ça m'a
intéressé jusqu'au moment où on a vu que
c'était qu'il y avait des bidons qui
avait des cafards
c'est compliqué pour elle après qu'elles
se frotte le corps excusez moi on n'est
pas sur une pub au barreau donc toi tu
as hâte a pas dérangé mais c'est à lui
qu'on s'arrête avant qu'elle prenne et
oui
brut est d'accord pour certaines à
séquence a été trop longue c'est pas
gênant soit moi je comprends ce ne soit
pas gênant mais en même temps ce n'était
pas utile step haïti où on est assez
d'accord là ça très bien rizzoli fait
peut-être que les spectacles et l'acp
l'été attendait des hommes je ne sais
pas non mais c'est vrai mais si on voit
des hommes classés c'est ce qu'on va
crier au scandale
ailleurs c'est tout le temps justement
ben oui c'est tout
c'est effectivement ce que j'entends à
s'équilibrer je donne raison sur la cedh
en elle-même je pense que la production
réduits à minima demander l'autorisation
aux candidats de les diffuser mais avec
magali je suis là connaissent quelqu'un
qui rejoint un tel programme équivalent
totalisèrent j'allais du coup lorsqu'on
rejoindront gamme comme pékin express
qui est aussi une télé réalité il faut
aussi se mettre dans la tête que ça fait
partie du jeu peut-être qu'à des images
qui vont sortir qui vont pas nous plaire
parce que la production par exemple si
elle tourne pendant une journée elle va
garder qu'une heure des images les plus
forts peut-être que ça sera notre
défaveur
mais ça fait partie du jeu si on voit là
de bien sûr donc voilà mais juste sans
laquelle il aurait pu demander monsieur
gilles ducout envie de demander à kevin
est ce que cette nouvelle adaptation
elle sait pas chuter les audiences parce
qu'on va passer quand même à moins de
cent mille téléspectateurs sur une
semaine au moins de cinq grammes moins
de 200 milles en une semaine fin après
le truc c'est qu'aujourd'hui je trouve
le mot de télé réalité un peu obsolète
aujourd'hui c'est de la série réalité le
problème c'est qu'on a aujourd'hui je
consomme année tu as peut-être confirmé
on efface aussi à des candidats mais qui
en fait veulent maîtriser tout de a à z
te ment pas donner l'image par exemple
en fait y'a plus la spontanéité qui
avait au départ dans ce type de
programme ils viennent avec un tel cv un
objet que voilà pourquoi on signe comme
tu l'as dit magali tu veux pas contre
montrant dans la douche et bain tu
dégages la caméra ou tu te montrerai pas
où tu attends attends jean pascal
toi tu étais au tout début dans ce type
de programme
à un moment tu oublies la caméra non ben
oui oui parce que nous en plus ont été
les précurseurs donc on savait pas quel
cas et nous combien de fois on a été on
avait un saut là on était en short on
n'y pense pas maintenant peut-être que
les temps ont changé on joue un petit
peu plus sur ce ton là mais il faut
quand on fait en jeu aujourd'hui à la
télé il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui on
est là pour faire de l'audience
on est là aussi pour créer des réseaux
reprennent tous donc il faut certains et
si les productions d'avant plus prévenir
tout le monde en dix ans
mi tiers il ya cette image ça te bats ça
te truc non mais il faut savoir dans
quoi on s'engage avant de faire ses jeux
points voilà moi je moi je le voudrais